le/la bernard respire mieux le
gouvernement de la caq accorde un droit
acquis aux étudiants étrangers comme
elle
l'apprenti photographe reste sur la voie
rapide pour demander une résidence
permanente
mais ça ne sera pas le cas pour ses
proches restés en france et qui espère
immigrés un jour au québec mais je pense
que s'apaisaient rêve pour les prochains
puis au niveau de l'économie aussi pour
le québec et vous toutes ces écoles mais
ça va chuter là donc je pense qu'il
devrait vraiment réviser leur décision
plus en détail à matane quatre
programmes sont menacés par la réforme
c'est plus de la moitié des programmes
techniques conséquence la direction
craint de perdre 200 étudiants sur les
700 que compte le petit collège
l'association étudiante n'a pas
l'intention d'en rester là
pétitions vidéos témoignages toutes
sortes d'activités se prépare c'était
vraiment important pour notre cégep de
faire bouger les choses
vraiment donc on va essayer de faire le
maximum de deux côtés pour les équipes
de direction ne fait aucun doute que la
réforme du gouvernement legault aura des
impacts majeurs dans toutes les régions
un étudiant ici reporter entre 15 et 20
mille dollars annuellement en b pense
donc pour le logement pour la nourriture
tout ça dans les restaurants qu'est ce
qui va arriver l'autre on parle de pas
loin de 5 millions d'impact économique
sur la maintenant dans nos toujours dit
que là les étudiants internationaux y
contribuer de façon vraiment
significative à enrichir notre milieu
quand enrichir notre milieu au plein au
plan économique mais enrichir notre
milieu au plan social c'est une région
ou complices et le bas-saint-laurent la
gaspésie la courte nord ce sont ces
régions là qui vont souffrir de sautes
la fédération des cégeps veut rencontrer
le gouvernement et espère encore le
faire reculer sur sa réforme sur
l'immigration
et si jean françois deschênes l'asie au
canada matin